okay moflow wants to know how does he
see his work relating to david
sinclair's biological clock
yeah um yeah interesting uh it's it's
funny i've been talking a lot i talked
to david recently and i i've been
thinking a lot about um people have been
asking me a lot about aging bioelectrics
of aging
um i i don't know i don't know what the
relationship between bioelectrics and
aging really is
um
i can tell you that
planaria as far as we can tell don't age
there's no such thing as an old
planarian they live forever if
you know if they're not injured and so
uh
i think what that tells us is that
aging
it would be resolved if we could crank
up regenerative capacity to the point
where we would constantly be
regenerating any to any cells that that
aged right senescing cells would just be
regenerated the way planaria do
so my sis my strong suspicion is that
aging is a is a
a consequence of our poor ability to
stay
with the appropriate anatomical
structure through long periods of time
and if we cracked that problem we would
simultaneously get the answer to to
aging uh cancer degenerative disease and
traumatic injury i think it all comes
down to the ability to to to defend a
particular body plan over time
i know many people say that telomere
length has to do with aging well the
shortened telomere length and you're
suggesting well it could be that but
it's also related to this
morphogenetic code that you're referring
to and
yeah are they interrelated somehow
probably i mean i am not an expert on
telomeres i have no idea what's going on
with telomeres in planaria i'm assuming
somebody's studying it we certainly
haven't i'm assuming somebody must be
all i know is
this this story of inevitable aging
because you keep making copies of things
and fundamentally things are the
information is degrading and eventually
you you don't have it anymore uh and
it's degrading at the ends because you
know because that's where you're eating
that that clearly cannot be the whole
story because planaria avoided
permanently so whatever they're doing
is uh is is is the way to get around
aging and i think it's more than a
coincidence that the species that is
immortal is also the species with the
greatest regenerative capacity or let's
say the set of species so i i don't
think that's a that's a that's a crazy
coincidence that i think there's there's
a reason for that